okay uh morning coffee thoughts part
part two oh gosh okay
another interesting thing about my dad
is my dad is very big on not telling
people what to do
i was in a relationship once he really
didn't agree with right
and he was telling me like
like
i would have some people tell me to
leave and this this this and this
or they would just like sugarcoat it you
know
but my dad he just has a funny way
a funny way of like handling things
right
he just looked at me one day and he says
do you like torture
you can do what you want i'm not going
to tell you what to do because then in
20 years if your life didn't turn out
the way you wanted you're going to blame
me and i'm not going to have that
but do you like torture
because you keep signing up for torture
why do you do that
and
like that was more influential to me
than anything
like he could have said and that's the
thing about my dad my dad is not the
type of boss that like
is
always down your throat like you do this
this this and this he he might not give
you enough attention that's probably his
probably flaw as a boss because
he's a busy guy you know what i mean
but
he's really big into not controlling
people
and it's interesting because the
manosphere is really big on like
some things
i'm sorry guys
they seem a little bit controlling you
guys describe some of your ideal
relationships
i wouldn't want to sign up for that and
it's because like
nobody wants to feel like controlled in
their whole life like
they might want direction and guidance
but
like the worst feeling was when i i
was in a relationship where i felt like
i wanted to do this youtube channel this
is something i love and i'm passionate
about and i couldn't do it because
like i couldn't do certain things
because you know of other people
and that's just how my dad like lives
his life and it's crazy because i have
never seen someone that has more control
over people without controlling them
because my dad is just the most logical
person i've ever met he's very wise he's
got a lot of common sense and he never
i mean he's a really good person
like
my dad doesn't lie he doesn't cheat he
doesn't steal like
my dad like like damn near doesn't do
any of that [ __ ] like he's never done
drugs in his life never smoked never
actually i think he told me he did a
cigarette in like third grade but like
you guys get the you get the gist
and so he just
has this like wisdom that
literally
has like influence over people
so
i don't know it's really interesting
because
he he has a lot of control and influence
but he doesn't
like tell people what to do ever he just
gives them the costs and the benefits
like there was a time okay i was liberal
for a little bit in college but not not
that long like it was very short-lived
mostly because of my dad
um
so
um i was like more conservative in high
school
and then in college um i don't know you
just kind of get
like warped and like the media and stuff
so for a little bit i kind of bought
into
i would never say i was like a full out
liberal but i kind of bought into like
some of the ideas i would just say
and
um one of them was i had a lot of guilt
i had so much guilt growing up for
growing up in a privileged family
i i felt so guilty that i had all this
stuff for free like i had these parents
that loved me like i had this this this
and this and all of these kids like are
stuck in college debt and
all and it wasn't like i was spoiled
i've never been one to like
spend a ton of money i've never been one
to like
piss on the opportunities i've always
been one to like work hard and try at
things
but i just felt really guilty and that's
why i always at that time i was really
into like free [ __ ] you know
government-wise
and my dad he
he told me something that changed my
mind
okay
he said hannah because for those of you
that don't know my first name is
actually hannah
it's it's not that you can't have social
programs it's two dollars in one dollar
out and i said dad like what do you what
do you mean two dollars in one dollar
out you can only have so many programs
where you're putting two dollars in and
taking one dollar out of something until
you run out
and he said
there are some things that you can like
make up for it
but you can't you can't have a million
programs that aren't making money
and that
forced me to be a conservative
and it's funny because if i take a
personality test if i take jordan
peterson's big five personality test it
says you're liberal like it says you are
without a doubt super loft because i
think if i didn't have my dad to give me
like guidance and wisdom
like i think i would have definitely
been left because i just think there's
something about men can like appeal to
you in a different way using like logic
that women can't like women can appeal
to your emotions
and my mom can appeal like if i am like
heartbroken and like crying like i don't
really want to go to my dad i want to go
to my mom i want to cry like cry with my
mom like you know
um but there's just something that like
dads like
pass on to you in terms of like wisdom
that i just think like women don't have
that same
effect usually
so i'm sure there's something like
candice once you can't tell me that
[ __ ] don't have wisdom
okay um all right i love you guys second
coffee thought of the day
um tune into my show tonight
9 30.
i'll talk to you guys later bye